if you could punch anyone in the world
who would you choose
so just a solid right hand
on on conor mcgregor's face
would be pretty
will be pretty satisfying
[Music]
why haven't you fought ksi yet uh yeah
look that good question i have tried
so hard with this team to make that
happen i'm ready i'll i'll fight him
anywhere anytime anyplace i've said we
can do it in london you could be the a
side i think he just knows what will
happen especially now you know the guy
has been sitting on his computer making
trying not to laugh challenge videos
while i've been knocking out
professional boxers and sparring so i
you know i think it'd just be bad for
him to to take a l man this is a grown
ass man sitting in his room doing trying
not to laugh challenges i'm just it's
not for me
tommy fury said you won't fight him
because you've got no balls
what's your response to him
i um
recently went
to my doctor and he in fact
confirmed that i do have two balls i
have two balls i i'm looking at him
right now
this guy uh this guy
he doesn't want the smoke with me man
he doesn't want it
he uh he fights
because his dad
and his brother fight i fight for a
completely
way different reason than that and
when someone tells you to be a fighter
it it doesn't last
you have to want to be a fighter for
yourself
do you still have floyd mayweather's hat
i do not have his hat that was the one
thing when like all the 20 guys were on
top of me i was like i gotcha
i got it they were like just give us the
hat just give us the hat i was like no
no and then like three of them started
prying it out of my one hand and then
when i gave them the hat back they they
got off of me so i think they just
wanted the hat
if you could punch anyone in the world
who would you choose
so just a solid right hand
on on conor mcgregor's face
would be pretty
we'll be pretty satisfying
what will happen in the woodley fight
i'm gonna knock out tyron in less than
two rounds he's gonna face plant onto
the canvas
like a bad bmx fall like when the guys
go over the hannah ballers and smash
into the canvas that's what's gonna
happen preparation breeds confidence my
team's amazing i'm amazing i've done
everything right
so
there's there's nothing i haven't done
to win this fight where do you see
yourself in five years time
five years from now
i think i uh will be a retired world
champion boxer
you've received a lot of hate online
does it ever affect you yeah i think i
think you know when i was a bit younger
and first experiencing
you know
a lot of the a lot of the hate and the
comments and seeing all of it it would
if it affected me a lot it's not an easy
thing to go through even if you like try
to ignore it or try to like oh that
doesn't bother me
it sort of always like creeps up on you
and is like yeah that that that bothers
me i've learned to deal with it and i've
learned to become confident in myself i
think boxing has
helped out a ton with that and now i'm
you know using my foundation boxing
bullies to to try and fight back against
bullying and have a voice against cyber
bullying are there any other sports you
would try your hand at i've thought
about going and uh doing some nfl
workouts after boxing there's sort of
like an itch
in the back of my head like man go to
the nfl just just to say i did it you
know i'm fast i can i can run a
4.4 second 40 yard dash
if you could have a beer with a
celebrity you haven't met who would it
be man that's a good question i honestly
think i would pick shia labeouf
i uh watch one of his interviews and he
just seems like a very interesting guy
that i think i have like a lot in common
with you can just tell there's like a
lot going on in his mind and
he's a bit older than me and so i and i
think he's gotten to a point where he's
able to like
express himself i've struggled with that
a little bit like how do i express
myself as the artist so i kind of like
looked up to how he was able to like do
that and uh
and become a master of his craft
i'm apparently invisible and i thought
this only worked in a wwe ring when my
opponent was incapacitated
but it actually also works on the
internet i think am i invisible
i don't know
at points i think i am and then there
are points i wish i was and then there
are points i know i'm not
so
i don't know if it's dangerous but
i got a superpower so
you can't see me